You just finished building your application and it looks great.
If we stop here because you're ready to rest, right?
its wrong.
I'm David East, and I'm here to convince you that you're not over yet,
Because you need to build a tool.
But first, what is the tool?
Well, the tool is a single display that passes to another application,
As the main screen application.
This offer is displayed as part of its design.
This view becomes a window to access your app
From the Home or Lock screen.
Here the magic begins,
You can use that tool to display information that is important to your app users
And to bring them back to your app.
This means that you have the opportunity
To be an essential part of the mobile user experience.
This is very cool.
Take for example a single non-interactive tool,
As a weather application.
It can display the temperature above a bright sun,
Quickly show the weather on the home screen.
You have now got a grateful user,
Because they do not have to open the application
Just to lose the weather.
But tools can do things, not just display information.
So supply this presentation with the information done.
Click on the offer The user should be taken to a deep link in your app
But do not just move it to the basic activity view.
But instead think of another suitable place,
Such as the weather report for the week.
Another useful tool is the status switch.
You may want to display the signal strength of the wireless network at the moment.
This is your offer.
A click on this display may turn on or off the network,
Without having to go to the Settings application.
This is very useful.
But these are just simple hints of what these tools can do for you and your users.
For example the calendar tool.
Where the display can change its size to fill any space given to it by the user
While viewing all events on this day.
Clicking the event will go to its details page.
Scrolling through the list will show you everything you can not offer.
Your view of the list does not mean that you can not add a quick add button,
So to create a new event easily and with a single click.
The tools are great, because they enable you to make your application useful to users,
Even if they do not open them.
You can then return users to your app,
Because you are tempted by the completion of some work.
So, check out the documentation to learn more about the tools
And look at what tools can do for you.
But most important is to continue to build better applications.